when it comes to audio Razer is known
for its headsets but with the release of
its Leviathan sound bar and subwoofer
combo it's taking a stab at the living
room with Dolby virtual speakers Dolby
Digital and Dolby Pro Logic 2 technology
the Leviathan simulates 5.1 surround
sound by converting analog stereo and
digital audio signals from your PC
gaming console home theater receiver
blu-ray player or mobile device
essentially anything with a
three-and-a-half millimeter audio jack
optical audio port or Bluetooth radio
will work just fine you can even connect
a portable NFC enabled device with a
quick tap on the sound bar to Razors new
sound bar is comprised of two foreign
speakers and two small tweeters the
controls on the top of the unit control
power volume input selection bluetooth
pairing and equalizer settings including
profiles for games movies and music the
unit also comes with two sets of
swappable feet for the sound bar so that
you can angle it forward or slightly
upwards depending on your needs the
Leviathans downward firing subwoofer is
technically a passive speaker but it is
boosted by the sound bars internal 30
watt amplifier it's worth noting that
the system does not come with a remote
and there's no visual reference for the
current volume level razor just started
shipping the Leviathan which sells for a
suggested retail price of $200 for your
money you might be able to get better
sounding speakers but the Leviathan is a
good looking an affordable option if
you're interested in graduating from
stereo audio from your TV and it has
Bluetooth support so you can use it with
your phone as well while it's not the
same as true surround sound the
Leviathan is definitely a step up from
traditional to speaker setups for more
gaming hardware and tech coverage stay
tuned to game tech at GameSpot calm